double coverage flick the Book Fairs tab
on our website at book TV Norg welcome
I'm Bradley Graham I'm the co-owner of
politics and prose along with my wife
listen Muscatine and on behalf of the
entire PNP staff thank you thank you
very much for coming
well survival that's the that's the big
topic that we're here to talk about this
evening as mankind looks to the future
and we certainly do face some very big
survival challenges that basically come
down to how to provide food clean water
and energy to an ever-growing population
on a planet undergoing climate change
Charles Mann has written an engrossing
book about these challenges but not with
the purpose of providing his answer to
how we all should cope rather he is very
engaging Lee and helpfully framed the
debate by writing about two 20th century
scientists who though not particularly
well known were exceptionally
influential Charles says the two were
largely responsible for creating quote
the basic intellectual blueprints for
understanding our environmental dilemmas
now these two didn't agree in fact they
took radically different approaches to
the issue of survival one was Norman
Borlaug a Nobel Prize winning agronomist
who developed high-yield wheat varieties
and championed agricultural techniques
that led to the Green Revolution a
vastly increasing world food production
the other was william vote an
ornithologist who studied the
relationship between resources and
population and wrote the 1948 bestseller
road to survival founding document of
modern environmentalism that predicted
trends
would lead to overpopulation and mass
hunger Borlaug and vote represents two
sides of a dispute between what Charles
calls the Wizards who believe that
science and technology will enable
humans to continue prospering and the
prophets who warn of disaster unless we
accept the earth's resources are limited
and cut back accordingly now Charles is
a journalist a correspondent for the
Atlantic science and wired who is
focused on science technology and
commerce and as a journalist he doesn't
appear to side with either of his
biographical subjects but he is a
skilled storyteller as he showed in a
couple of his previous books 1491 and in
a companion volume 1493 about the age of
Columbus immediately before and after
the discovery of the Americas and
reviews of his new book the wizard and
the prophet have praised not only his
lively narrative style but also his
ability to make complicated subjects
accessible Bill McKibben the prominent
environmentalist wrote in a New York
Times review that Charles's book quote
provides detail enough and simplicity
enough that anyone who is struggling
with these puzzles will be enlightened
and informed and entertained which given
the subject matter is no small feat now
Charles will be in conversation with
Scott Stossel the editor of the Atlantic
a magazine that Scott first joined in
1982 1992 Scott also is the author of a
biography of Sargent Shriver and of the
best-selling my age of anxiety which
Scott spoke about here at P&P three
years ago so ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming Charles and Scott
[Applause]
yeah this one's own Scott was a 92 or 89
I would have loved to join the Atlantic
when I was 12 but get you guys wired up
here in a second this on is this huh
yeah yeah well thank you all for coming
and thank you Charles for joining us
tonight
I've just taken up my jacket because I'm
a heavy sweater but also because this is
a heavy topic you know future of the
survival of the species
yeah but I wanted to and let me pull out
my so I've been a reader and fan of
Charles man's books for 25-30 years at
this point so it's a real privilege and
a pleasure to sit here and talk to you
all about the book and to talk to
Charles as it has been to actually
excerpt the book and in and I'm gonna
give it a little plug for the Atlantic
in the current issue of the Atlantic
which will be out in a few days we
published a very nice extract from the
book this will not translate well on TV
if you're looking at this on c-span but
trust me this rewards it's got a Where's
Waldo quality to it that will
ward close scrutiny and without further
ado let me let me let me start right in
so you begin the book as you actually
begin the excerpt of our article by
talking about an anecdote when your
daughter was born some couple decades
ago 20 years yeah almost 20 years and
you walk out from the hospital and have
certain thoughts talk about that well if
any of you are male who's had children
you know that there's this entire
industry that exists to try to convince
you that you have something to do with
the childbirth and so they make you go
to these classes and then you go to the
childbirth and then there's at least in
my experience there's a whole platoon of
people who are constantly telling you
how important it is that you're there
and how very very vital you are to the
what's going on and then at the end
after the child is born the everything's
right they throw you out because the
people actually done something need to
have some rest and so inevitably this is
at 3 o'clock in the morning and so this
was February in Massachusetts and I was
standing in the parking lot sort of
blown away by what had just happened
and then if thought popped into my head
that when my daughter was born there'd
be almost 10 billion people in the world
and I thought whoa and I of course I'd
known this before but maybe I'd
eventually be 10 billion people
eventually yeah when she was my age I'm
sorry excuse me when my door was when I
when she became my age there'd be about
10 billion people in the world and I
think centuries from now when people
look back at the time that I've been
alive and many of you have been alive
the big event that they're going to talk
about historians is that hundreds of
millions of people in Asia and Latin
America and lesser extent Africa pulled
themselves from out of destitution into
something like the middle class so not
only will there be 10 billion people but
a whole lot of them will be middle class
and they'll want all the things we want
you know a nice bookstore you know a
nice black jacket occasional treats at
one point I was going to call the book
Toblerone Ian for 10 billion
I thought that's a great title manager
and so then these ten billion people
they're gonna want all this stuff right
so how are we gonna provide it know how
is that going to work and as Scott
mentioned I'm a science journalist and
you know from time to time after that
when I would talk to people we'd hit it
off
we'd have cup of coffee afterwards I
would say hey listen you know in 2050 I
have my explain my little idea what are
we gonna do and after a while I realized
the answer is fell into that they were
giving me fell into these two broad
categories and they also kept mentioning
these names Borlaug and vote and who I
had sort of vaguely heard of and then
after a while I thought you know this is
pretty interesting what they're saying
so what he should write a book I have to
point out and I don't this is not gonna
be visible to any of you from far away
or on TV you anticipate my next question
which did you really actually almost
call this book Toblerone II for 10
billion it's right here here up close up
but actually the reason reason I want to
ask you about that I have a specific
reason not just cuz it's a silly title
because it's actually a very apt title
and it would be cryptic but it's not
just about so one of the core the core
of theses of your book is that the one
of the factual basis for it is that that
you know not that long from now 2025
years from now there will be 10 billion
people in the world and a significantly
larger number and percentage of them
will be middle-class than in the past
and it's not like they want to just
survive although of course they do they
want to eat in the manner in which we of
residents of upper middle upper
Northwest Washington are accustomed to
eating right and why wouldn't they and
why wouldn't they right so so so so so
talk about this is kind of the core
thrust of your book so then the question
is how we're gonna do this because you
know it's one thing to keep 10 billion
people alive at a very low level it's
another thing to provide it with with
Toblerone II you know and the reason I
thought
that that was a great title although I
apparently am in the minority on this
because you're the second editor it's
called it a silly title exactly that's
literally the word my editor said it's
exactly that nobody will understand what
it means right but yeah is it is that
environmental books and books on this
subject I have a whole raft of them and
obviously they appeal to a certain
number of people but for an awful lot of
people including sometimes me they sort
of seem like homework they seem like you
know exactly what you don't want to read
and so here I as you know part of this
big fat is clearly a book with this big
fat subject that was gonna be all about
everything most people don't want to
read and I sort of hope that if I call
it something silly not actually but that
maybe it might hint it might be actually
interesting war people might think it
was a book about chocolate distribution
which I think that'll be good exact my
one point I've wrote this book 1491 and
new revelations of the Americas before
Columbus was a subtitle and I went to my
editor I said I'm worried that people
will think that this is a spiritual New
Age book and he said your point is well
good let's get to the fee manic core of
the book which you've sort of alluded to
but it's called the Wizards and the
prophets or the wizard and the prophet
you have a specific standing in each in
each case who are the Wizards who is the
actual wizard who are the prophets who
is the Prophet and why should we care
okay well what they these guys did you
know again this is basically because I
would talk to these people and I
realized that these answers fell into
these two broad categories I mean these
two names kept coming up one of them is
Norman Borlaug and what he is is the man
who's the primary figure in what's been
called the Green Revolution which is the
combination of high yielding seeds high
intensity fertilizer and irrigation that
doubled tripled or even quadrupled grain
yields across the world in the 1970s and
1980s and if you were a
in the 1960s it was quite commonly
believed that there being massive
starvation's hundreds of millions of
people would die in famines and that
didn't happen and one big reason for
that was the was the Green Revolution
this enormous increase in in harvests
and so he has become the emblem for the
idea that Science and Technology
properly applied will allow us to
produce our way out of these questions
it'll say be smart make more we can you
know harness the this lead these forces
and we can just simply cruise on as
we've been doing talk about the profit
okay the profit is William Vogt and
who's a much more obscure figure and he
is the guy who first put together the
fundamental ideas of the environmental
movement he put him in this book the
road to survival which is the first
modern we're all going to hell book if
you know what I mean and so if you read
Silent Spring or Al Gore's first book
earth in the balance or Population Bomb
or the limits to growth or any of these
kind of classics that many of us had to
read in college all of their ideas stem
from from him and he is the guy who
first took a concept that had been
floating around ecology for a few years
at that point called carrying capacity
and that's the idea that an individual
environment can only support so many so
much so that if you have a meadow
you can only a certain number of horses
can graze on it before they eat up all
the grass and the meta won't be
productive anymore and he said the earth
has a carrying capacity and this is
called now a bunch of different names
ecological limits planetary boundaries
but the basic idea is that there are
these natural cycles natural resources
and if we consume too much of them we're
gonna wreck the whole thing and very bad
consequences will will follow from that
and if you think about these two answers
are kind of the opposite from each other
one is saying make more in a smart way
and the other thing because so that way
everybody can win and the other one is
saying no no you know hunker down and
conserve in that way otherwise everyone
will lose and this is part of what makes
Charles's book such a brilliantly a
brilliant serve explanatory framework
for understanding these things and
here's something I'm gonna keep coming
back to I'm gonna start right now you
are assiduously careful in the book not
to come down on one side or the other
I'm trying to be fair I know well but I
know you want to be fair but we also
want to be a tower Grinch we want our
grandchildren to be able to eat in 2050
right so what why you so which side is
right well I I'm asking this seven times
before this is all right well you skip
this point cuz in a certain way the
answer is I don't know it's a pretty you
know because that involves predicting
the future and if there's one thing that
I have learned I am terrible at it is
predicting the future I mean you know
everything that has happened in the last
20 years of American politics
I would nope Donald Trump's cover your
present nope you know everything so if
you yeah if I predict it is gonna be
wrong so that so I've been burned by
this so a much stronger ground saying
what I see around me okay and which is
that there's these two alternative
approaches and both of them involve big
leaps into the unknown yeah and both of
them are fundamentally based on live
life we want to lead rather you know at
the bottom rather than some sort of
practical consideration and so when you
think about energy how are you miss
apply energy for everyone what the
Wizards want to do is have big
centralized facilities typically with
nuclear power and they'll give you all
these sort of practical reasons for it
but what they really like about it is
that you have everything concentrated in
one place it feeds out to everyone else
and only a small number people have to
be involved in it and it sort of
maximizes personal liberty for everybody
involved
whereas what the profits like you know
are these sort of Network small scale
solar and wind installations that are
under neighborhood control and they see
this as a much more democratic way of
living and but if when these discussions
having these so the prophets will say to
the Wizards oh you don't know how to
deal with the waste you don't know how
you know they're way too expensive the
Wizards will say oh you know it's so
complicated and you know networking then
we don't know how to do this and all
these arguments are both true and sort
of bogus because what they're really
about is I don't want to live the way
you want they do want to live that's a
good answer I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
coming back at you with this again and
again and you'll keep you know
fundamentally answering but I hope in a
way that will be helpful II elucidating
well no no in particular here's the next
question so isn't there a middle ground
I mean you're talking about you know
you've got the Wizards and the prophets
they each have different and maybe the
reason is and maybe I meant to spit in
your answer they've got different value
systems but why isn't the answer you
know the prophets would say we need
value system adjustments we need we need
lifestyle adjustments we need to live
differently we cannot continue to live
as we have been and expect that the
earth will survive and that we will
survive the Wizards say again and again
technology has come to the rescue
there'll be some breakthrough like
Norman Borlaug in the nineteen sixties
with the Green Revolution we'll do it
again can't be a little of both you know
will mate will have some technological
breakthroughs will adjust at the margins
or maybe not so much the margins and
we'll all be fine well there's nothing
there's like no law of physics that's
saying that so the answer is of course
yes there can be a little of both but
it's interesting that these people have
been fighting for decades and it just
hasn't shown up and so you know it's a
little bit like saying you know two
Republicans Democrats can't we all just
get along and the answer is of course we
can but it doesn't seem likely that
doesn't happen yeah you divide the
dwindling resources that the world faces
into I think four categories and they're
more than that but but but if you
construe the broadly water food energy
and then climate change which is right
there cheesy schema that I have you know
the four elements so earth could you
climate change is the fourth yeah but
it's there yeah so earth air fire and
water so earth is agriculture water is
fresh water fire as energy supply and
then air is climate change but let me
put you on the spot rank order those in
terms of the threat that they pose to
the planet and to your and my and all of
our grandchildren
and their generational peers in
particular in you know where all these
new people are going to be coming from
in Africa and and and and Asia in terms
of their ability to not just survive but
thrive
okay well water is the most immediate I
mean that they happen on different
scales I mean you know as you I don't
know if you guys been following the news
out of Cape Town or caked-on is
literally running out of water and a
whole lot of that has to do with really
stupid management and and issues that we
can talk about if you want to but that's
actually quite immediate there's places
like Jordan that are really seriously in
in in trouble so that's the most
immediate its I also think they're both
its lickable but it's very definitely an
immediate problem and then I would say
food comes after that in terms of you
know scale in time and then for your
grandchildren great-grandchildren its
climate change so it depends on when
you're asking it so it's basically like
basically a timed out over for Cape Town
you know they're not worrying about
climate change right now you know
they're trying to get water right zero
day is happening in next month I think
it is yeah when they when it's they
believe it'll literally run out of water
one of the most on each side there are
kind of gee whiz II solutions they're
probably more gee whiz II in the
conventional sense on the on the wizard
side and we in in the in the excerpt
that we published in the Atlantic it's
about sea for rice was about rice that
has been its ability to photosynthesize
has been genetically modified but on
both sides including the profits that
were them with radical solutions like
the technological moonshots Manhattan
projects on the wizard side and kind of
what are the things that we could do
that would you know maybe radically
change how we live as humans on this
earth that would actually make it so
that we can be assured that our children
and grandchildren are okay well there's
a bunch of room in fact I sort of wrote
this whole book about them but for
example the the sea for rice initiative
which I described both in the Atlantic
and in here is this amazing project it's
largely funded by the Bill Gates Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation
and it's an attempt to change the way
photosynthesis works in rice and this is
really serious genetic engineering most
genetic engineering involves taking you
know one or you know one to small number
of genes from some organism and just
essentially inserting them into another
organism and the classic example this
was a sort of paradigmatic example be
Roundup Ready soybeans in which there's
a gene from bacteria that was found in a
waste by waste pond in Louisiana that is
inserted into soybeans and you can spray
Monsanto's popular herbicide Roundup on
these soybeans and they won't be killed
and so you can kill the weeds but not
that herbicide and that's that's typical
of genetic engineering what the see for
rice initiative is bears the same
resemblance to that that a that is that
a Boeing 787 does to a paper airplane
it's just and just an enormous Lee
grander thing and whereas the bonne
santé people are basically doing this so
they can sell their goop you know
they're month they're roundup this is
being done to be given away there's no
there's no profit motive involved and
what they want to do is because a
non-profit is based in the Philippines
with this organization called the
International Rice Research Institute
and directed by people in Oxford and
that was an offshoot of the work that
Borlaug did in the 1950s and 1960s and
what they're trying to do is take
probably 30 or 40 genes that are
sleeping in rice and wake them up and
change the way it actually grabs a
carbon dioxide out of the air and to
make it much more efficient and so this
is really tinkering with the heart of
life and if you're the sort of person
who doesn't like GMOs genetically
modified organisms this is like going
exactly in the wrong direction and what
and what do you say to that I mean that
was my next question actually like this
is this is genetic modification squared
squared yeah
is that is it is that a priori a bad
thing is it
a priori a good thing I'm making this
easy for you
or how do we think about this well I
think the people who don't like genetic
modification basically what they don't
like is industrial agriculture and the
kind that we have with what they call
industrial monocultures are these huge
you know huge expanses of of single
crops you know tended by huge machines
in essentially empty countryside that is
you know being completely depopulated
they just don't like the whole thing
they see that as a problem and certainly
has caused enormous environmental
problems and so for them the idea of
trying to prolong it and to extend it
and make it you know even even grander
is like trying to put out a fire by
point gasoline on it it's exactly the
wrong thing to do and so the prophets
say instead why don't we have farms that
much more mimic natural ecosystems and
change the mix of crops that we grow for
instance we can grow trees and tubers
which are much more productive than then
grain and reconfigure the way that we do
agriculture in a way that doesn't cause
the environmental problems associated
with industrial monocultures and the
wizards day oh that's a complete recipe
for going backwards you know there's no
productive we won't be able to grow
enough food and you know this is it and
it's gonna tie up all these people
working there because these farms so
much more complicated nobody wants to
work on farms it's horrible work you're
romanticizing agriculture and it's not
fun and and so on so that there's a real
difference of opinion about what's
desirable here and until you ask you
this question seven times so this is I
think the third time who's right well
what do you like I mean you know the the
you know the the the only way that the
profits efficient will work is if a
certain number of the people we now have
like two and a half percent of the
Americans working on farms all right and
in the book I compared two farms that
are side-by-side one is any sort of
wizards farm one it's a sort of profits
farm and the the wizards farms you know
droves genetically modified corn
genetically modified wheat and is 1200
acres and it has only one and a half
people working on it and two or two or
three million dollars worth of farm
equipment yeah that's pretty good
yeah well
if you hate farming right you know
farming but if you don't you know the
other one has five hundred twenty seven
acres grows a thousand different
varieties you know huge numbers of
different different crops it's
incredibly complicated system and it has
eleven full-time employees and 30-plus
part-time employees the two guys here
are the farmer and his son I've both
them with high school degrees over there
they have two people with master's
degrees in agronomy because the system
so doggone complicated and if you want
to go here you're gonna have to convince
people to live here and that means you
have to raise prices somehow you're
gonna have to subsidize that subsidize
that labor or raise prices or do
something so it makes it attractive for
people to live here but farm a versus
farm B is question number four which is
farm a being the Wizards farm B being
the profits with the eleven employees
which produces more output it's it's
actually this is incredibly complicated
this is a sort of thing there's a
zillion studies and they and all the
people fight about it because it you
know for instance the in terms of just
sheer pounds the organic one
quote-unquote organic produces more the
profits farm produces more but because
there's so many different crops they
have a lot more water in in them so you
so do you you count the water you know
do do this if you count the water they
probably produce less but they also use
many fewer farm chemicals so the inputs
don't count as much so the cost to
produce that less and then they also
point out that has less erosion and and
so forth externality is anything whereas
these guys are supported by this so it
turns out that you can really spend a
long time fighting about this and that's
exactly what numerous academics have
done and the answer is we don't know
anything else we don't know right
we've just to expand either one on the
kind of scale that's necessary to feed
the ten billion is a big leap in the
dark so tell the story you you have a
anecdote in your book about about being
in a coffee shop when when the great I
think late biologist Lynn Margulis comes
in she lived in my town she was a famous
microbiologist and she can never tell
that tell that story germane to your
alright she basically thought I was a
sin
Milsap nice you know nice but you know
but it about saps are usually very nice
yeah right and so I was reading Al
Gore's book about climate change and you
finally get around to reading it and she
taps him his shoulder and I sort of
crouched because linen is the surfaces
like to poke you you know and and I
think she liked me but she also really
like watch me squirm and apparently you
do too I apparently attract really
because you you're very good at laying
out positions and then and and very sort
of existing and it kind of equipoise
between the two of them I think that's a
nice way of saying I'm were me and
you're anyway so she taps me on the
shoulder she grabs the book and she
doesn't say anything but her just this
very eloquent look of disdain on her
face and I say you know what what you
know the way you would and she flips and
there's like a picture of an endangered
polar bear or something there and she
sort of rolls her eyes goes mammals yeah
and the reason was is that she thought
this was that she's a microbiologist and
she knows that bacteria and protists and
fungi and algae you know a little micro
world makes up 99% of the world's
biomass and 99% of the world's
evolutionary creativity and mammals like
us you know from that point of view were
just we're an Epiphone Amin on we're
just we she thought we were cute but not
actually important you know are you all
worked up about endangered species he
wants that demand feebly tried to defend
myself right and I said Lynn what don't
you don't you think we'll be sad if like
we wake ourselves out through climate
change and she said you know what it's
the fate of every successful species to
wipe itself out and and what she meant
was that if you think about it what
Darwin's rules are you know there's a
evolution is that it applies to
everything you know that we are the same
rules biological rules apply we're not
special she would also say oh you
think we're special and we're not we're
just one species you know among all that
all the others all the rules applied to
us we're not special and you know if you
put a bunch of protozoa on a petri dish
though there there's no predators
nothing keeping him in check and they'll
just eat the goo you know on the bottom
the nutrients and expand and expand and
then they'll hit the edge of the petri
dish and then bad things will happen
either they'll drown in their own wastes
or they'll run out of resources or both
and that's what's the successful species
do when zebra mussels come into American
rivers they expand and expand and they
expand like the Hudson River and they
become 99% of the biomass in the Hudson
River and then they crash it isn't like
the zebra mussels sick oh we're gonna
run out of food we better stop
reproducing so quickly and eating so
much they just go right to the edge and
so people are gonna do the same thing
and we should just stop whining about it
that was her you know oh this could this
is another potential title for your book
could have been the edge of the petri
dish yeah no I thought about that tape
and and
and we there's many ideas and they're
all shot down by people like you know
sound it's actually a wonderful editor
but I am enjoying the chance to you know
feebly attack him but well so actually
this getting is so your your encounter
with with with with with Lynn Margulis
actually gives us an opportunity to kind
of take it to a higher Sur almost
biological we're already on a biological
level but but a theological evolutionary
rank level and I know you you you know
it in the book and actually in a piece
that you have forthcoming in in an in an
another online journal you talk about
sort of the debate between Wilberforce
and Darwin and Huxley actually and
Huxley you know the choice between sort
of religion and that's the idea that man
is in some way substantially distinct in
a rational I think it's the word you're
like that special yes versus the idea of
that know the stuff of man is the stuff
of flatworms
and amoeba and zebra
and giraffes all of which are beautiful
in their own way but the I think and I'm
a garbling this but it was Wilberforce I
think who said look if you buy this
argument aren't we just saying that men
and women humans are just a bunch of
overachieving mushrooms yeah thats
exactly what he said this is a famous
debate if you take biology you know 101
as I did the summer somewhere a long
line you'll hear about the Wilberforce
Huxley debate which occurred about six
or seven months after Darwin published
the Origin of Species and the there is
the British there was a meeting of the
British Association for the Advancement
of Science in Oxford and then Bishop
Wilberforce was a prominent English
bishop at the time and th Huxley who was
Darwin's one of Darwin's most dogged
defenders had a clash and the debate
itself is actually you know as these
things are basically turned into an
exchange of name-calling not a
substantive debate but and it's sort of
disappointing because your textbook will
tell you what a great debate it was and
then I read you read about and it's like
nothing but it became nonetheless this
important event and it's taken in the
textbooks to be this time when the wars
between science and religion began and
and if you read the accounts typically
they say that science won and
Christopher Hitchens the famous atheist
and many other things would like to
write about you know what a dunderhead
the bishop was and how smart Huxley how
smartly Huxley dispatched him but the
interesting thing is that what
Wilberforce was saying was that if you
really bought by this people aren't
special we don't have in he put it in
terms of a soul you know where's the
soul whereas where is this but you can
you don't have to put that religiously
you could say do we have a special spark
you know something that burns at the
nape of the neck and confers in us the
ability to do things that others don't
the other species can't and the odd
thing is that if you're any kind of
conservationist and you're hoping we
don't hit the edge of the petri dish you
end up citing was will for Wilberforce
and the point that Lynne was marvelous
was trying to make to me
when we talked about you know Wizards
and prophets and so forth is from her
the viewpoint the difference between
them was illusory because they're both
you know saying that we're special you
know to say that we're going to save
ourselves through technology or say that
we're gonna save ourselves through
conservation it doesn't matter the point
about saving yourself
we're claiming or special and we're not
it's her point of view and what's your
point of view well I I think that this
is why I'll tell you and I I was really
sort of shook up by this uh because you
know what is the evidence that were
special
look I if my obituary said he was an
overachieving mushroom I'd be okay with
yeah and so you know I mean what would
we you know and she Lin died in 2011 so
I you know I didn't have a chance to
argue this right I did think as I was
writing a book what could I say that
would be not just but you elicit the
response from her oh you're saying we're
special you know - you know what about
art oh you're special you know what I
mean I mean that's a good question yeah
that's gonna help us survive I can just
hear us saying do you think that's gonna
do it okay the spider webs are really
pretty that's gonna help them yeah you
know that kind of thing she was pretty
remorseless and so so here's the best
answer I could have given her and which
is you know cast your mind back to 1800
you know the world looks politically
very different but in other ways it's
profoundly different in ways that even
hard for us to imagine in 1800 slavery
exists around the entire world as it has
since as far as we know in fact the
oldest legal records we know over the
Code of Hammurabi and what it's
basically about is when it's okay to buy
and sell other human beings
so slavery is a totally foundational
institution it's legal everywhere in the
world it's important everywhere in the
world as it has been since it since time
immemorial and then in a few decades
this in 1800 according to this historian
Adam Hochschild - I think it's 2 out of
3 people in the world are in his
estimate are unfree and you know in one
way or another
you know they're in bonded labor and so
he says you know then in less than a
hundred years this institution that's
completely dominated human society for
as long as we know it disappears they're
still slaves around you know the
International Labour Organization says
there's 25 million of them or something
like that but nowhere in the world is it
accepted and legal yeah so we're back in
1800 look at look at women can't vote
anywhere they can't own property in I
think anywhere they can't dump their
husbands anywhere they can't participate
in the public sphere
you know the lists of things it's it's
easier to list the things that women can
do than wonder than the ones that they
can't do this is much shorter and this
you know in a few short decades in the
20th century changes dramatically
obviously neither these changes have
fully happened but its enormous ly
different right now half the people in
this audience are women and that just
would not have been the case in 1800 in
some similar gathering and the
subjugation of women by men is also this
profoundly foundational human
institution and yet it has changed so
people can change enormous lee and i
guess my feeling is and now you're
finally answering your question is if we
could do all this what a drag it would
be if we blew climate change
I mean all that progress and then they
just run out of yeah just how
disappointing although I love the way
you frame it I think you have language
in there if I may I might have written
it down it sounds like the prospectus
for an investment port
past successes do not guarantee future
progress what to say that like the
erosion of slavery was not just a blip I
mean you're putting a lot of weight on
the last couple hundred years of history
as opposed to the previous 10 million
while in yeah well I mean obviously
you're right that that could be a blip
it would it would be really a drag but
that would be total it could be totally
oblivion predict the future but you know
that would be the evidence I have that
we have done these changes in the in the
past and it and another one is the
decline in violence
this is something that the senior and I
there's some issues of some of his
argument but the basic idea that over
the last few thousand years you know
violence between nations and cultures is
declined I think is completely true and
it's really fallen off a cliff since the
Second World War which is really weird
because we hear about Syria and so forth
but it's a but every sort of Institute
for peace and so forth that I know of
believes this to be true so the last
time I'll ask you this quiet of this
question given what you've just said
about the very hopeful note about the
diminution of slavery of subjugation of
women this is all does that guide you to
one side or the other of the you know
prophets or the or the or the wizard or
is that is that is that a sort of
specious jump and and if you had to cast
your lot with work looking for this way
if you had to cast your lot with one of
the other as a betting man on your
children and your grandchildren your
great vengeance life who would you cast
it with I mean it well on which course
society will follow or which sources
would be the best well actually that's a
good question both well you know the
momentum is generally with the Wizards
that doesn't mean it has to be that way
but you know that is where you know the
momentum generally has been is that a
good thing you know that I'm just
stating a fact yeah okay
no I don't know another way of phrasing
this would be on some level the prophets
are obviously right the earth is finite
you know there's only so many molecules
there you know at some point limits kick
in the question is whether those limits
are relevant you know if the limits kick
in there's one of the things that I sort
of had fun with is an early kind of
prophet was a guy named Warren Weaver
who is a you know very involved in the
theory of information and and so forth
quite a remarkable guy and even said
what people need is what he called
usable energy and so he calculated how
much energy falls on the earth in the
form of the Sun and then he's
there there is room for 800 billion
people in the United States and based on
that one has obviously nobody want to
live like that but but but the point is
that what he was saying is yes there is
a limit but it's irrelevant for what
concerned and what's striking to me
after you about these debates is how
very little effort has been made into
establishing exactly what those limits
are yeah and so I would be much more
comfortable answering your question if
if there is like some group of
researchers who really thoroughly did it
and quite in recent years with the
planetary boundaries people people begun
doing that but it's still really shaky
stuff well let's open it up to questions
now we got please come up to the you can
line up here at the microphone here and
we'll take questions one of time while
we wait for people to line up let me ask
you this is a you've written a lot about
a lot of technological scientific stuff
is there any imaginable scenario in
which the answer is migration to the
Moon or Mars or other planets well it
depends what the question is
well the question is the solution to the
the finite resources on earth and the
explaining population well you know you
can't actually live on Mars you know
that right what you have to build a lot
of stuff they have to be able to live on
there hey there I read right today
there's a penny on there but anyway on
the Mars
someone left dropped a penny there yeah
excellent no okay on the petri dish and
the multi organisms that live there
compared to the earth or gear gee I
forget the exact pronunciation of the
term for the total earth is one organism
does it doesn't mans and womans
consciousness do away with the formula
of the usual species didn't it make us
unique as far as consciousness awareness
and self-determination
well are you Amy or Lynn Margulis you
yes clearly you know we possess the type
of consciousness that as far as we know
doesn't exist anywhere else but the
question is whether that will make any
difference
almost every species is unique it's
something we're also uniquely good at
throwing you know but that unique
attribute we're probably not save us so
the question is really you know in
something our children's generations I
find out is whether that does make us
special right and I have the feeling
that if we made it out you know for the
next century that even Lynn Margulis
might concede that we had something that
we weren't just a bunch of overachieving
mushrooms thank you only one mic here
tonight thanks very much I really enjoy
it I appreciate the the agnostic
position that you sort of take on things
and certainly the structure of this
prophet versus wizard and so in that
vein and I haven't read the book or even
leaf through it enough to know the
answer but certainly one of the things
that is expected to happen in the
decades the same decades coming that
climate will climate change will be a
very severe problem and as well perhaps
population growth and other resource
limitations and so forth another thing
that's expected is you know through
technology and perhaps through
artificial intelligence kind of the need
for work will will decline maybe even
very substantially so it's one
hypothesis is that that fact means that
with a whole lot of with more people and
with more time on their hands and more
that that would sort of support the that
the world that has 11 farmers per
whatever unit of production versus one
and a half farmers per unit of
production especially if there are other
advantages to the world that has the 11
farmers in other words the profit side a
thing or the I hope being
enough for you to sort of get in here
this thing and you know until you do you
deal with this in the book and is that
you know the Wizards argue that the fact
that it's a smaller number of people can
produce so much all right exactly is is
a good thing right
and what you're suggesting is that if
there's not enough work for four people
for meaningful work that having a farm
like this you know with many many people
in it that would be a feature not a bug
that's right you're right and you know
if if those people can get decent jobs
and you know it with decent pay and one
of the things that's really striking is
that the systems that we have and I
thought just us it's you know Europe and
most other places in the world
subsidized is effectively subsidized the
replacement of people by machinery and
so this is you know a kind of social
engineering that's occurred around the
world and when you you know it could be
reversed
you know it's a human decision it could
be reversed right okay so is that is
that in the book yeah and I talked about
that question next question yeah I'm
kind of curious if you comment on that
that says a negative impacts of
immigration I mean I was shocked to read
that one of the problems we face is you
know if someone moves from El Salvador
to now if someone moves from El Salvador
the United States or from Syria to
Germany there's this immediate huge
increase in the demands of resources
from those populations because their
standard of living is over a very short
period of time increase so ironically
you know reducing immigration actually
conserves resources over the moderate
term which is kind of a very surprising
thing the second thing I want to ask you
is that - is it in places like the
United States or Western Europe where
people have achieved a fairly successful
or let's say stable middle-class
lifestyle the birth rates have gone down
substantially so there's been some hope
that as the rest of the world you know
has the opportunity to you know a
lifestyle of that sort that the demand
some portion of the demand through
increased population growth will be
reduced by you know the reduction and
their you know multiple childbirth that
occurs and so though that does not
outweigh the demands of a middle-class
lifestyle so I'm just kind of curious
you know how you look at those two
issues the birth rates you know have
declined all around the world except in
a few places like like parts of the
Middle East and bits and pieces of
Africa but in Asia Latin America there
really have fallen and they're quite
comparable to birth rates in the United
States so the sort of picture that it's
often in our heads of you know very high
birth rates outside of the developed
world is it's been outdated by the
events the last twenty or thirty thirty
years and you know it is also true that
those nations are rapidly
industrializing I mean the difference
between Mexico City when I first saw it
in 1982 and when I saw it again you know
most recently a couple years ago is
absolutely extraordinary the amount of
difference in prosperity in Latin
America Southeast Asia China India is
just absolutely incredible and so it is
true that a person who comes from a poor
country and goes to a rich country
increases demand just as you say but
those countries are getting wealthy so
much faster that that won't be true for
very long
thank you next one you when you say that
sort of both of these paths potentially
or theoretically have successful paths
from where we are now into a better
future they're different routes is there
a risk that by continuing to fight and
not choose we sort of just plateau where
we are for instance the profits
preventing the Wizards from taking us
into the future and we all just kind of
crash at our current consumption rates
well that's pretty grim I mean it's the
future right almost anything can can
happen and we have certainly have
demonstrated an ability to to mess
things up but you know then you're
you're getting me into agreeing with
linn-mar
you know dude right who would say we
won't choose in the right so when one
time I was complaining about you know
the government not doing anything about
climate change and she sort of looked me
and said well duh two questions so I'm a
soil scientists at the University of
Maryland and you know I debate a lot of
these things with my colleagues all the
time
what I find to be most true among you
know soil scientists AG scientists is
that we don't see it as a dichotomy you
know you've made it out to be Wizards
and prophets we say we do both so people
say are you pro GMO are you not pro GMO
and I would say and I think most of my
colleagues would say well we need both
you know we need organics we need so I'm
just wondering you know I think Borlaug
got his bachelor's degree in forestry as
I understand it so was he
environmentally you know how did that
influence his look on environmental
issues not at all really
okay and he went to University of
Minnesota and in those days there's a
big forest products industry in the
Upper Midwest and what they wanted was
people to tell them you know how to
grade trees and you know for for lumber
and and saw timber and to you know to
maximize production there the idea was
that these were big tree farms and he
took almost no ecology classes at all
which is strange because you know right
across over there in Wisconsin now the
Leopold was was teaching YouTube so
Borlaug didn't take soil science at all
he took he had an incredibly narrow
education and then he became a plant
pathologist which you know narrowed it
narrowed it further what he really did
is he went to central Mexico in the
1940s where he did his most important
work and he saw desperate poverty it was
extraordinarily poor there in the wind
waste that we really have hard time
imagining because it just doesn't exist
him how many places anymore
two-thirds of the people in Mexico at
the time didn't get enough to food to
eat all the time I mean that's two out
of three people it's just terrible
and he looked at this and he saw these
very eroded landscapes and he said that
these people are trying to scratch a
living out and he said we need to give
these people better tools and vote
actually
was in the same place at the same time
when he said my god we need to restore
these landscapes and stem from that and
you know you're absolutely right of
course we could do do both but it's
typically seems not to have happen that
way well you know it's just interesting
because of course the federal budget
right seventy nine billion dollars
non-discretionary I mean non-defense Rd
USDA gets about four billion dollars you
know so you just wonder if we were back
up at 11% the way we were in the 60s
what could we do in agriculture that you
know you could win on both sides so
that's really I think what the consensus
is among myself and my colleagues is we
just we don't have any money you know we
got the key problem getting the budget
back up that how in a time when you know
it's quite commonly estimated that we're
gonna have to grow twice as much food in
2050 to feed everybody at the level
which would be a custom now there's a
lot of arguments and back and forth
about that but that's that's a figure
you hear quite often and it's really
hard to imagine why it's a good idea to
cut the funds available to the people
were actually gonna have to produce do
this thank you thank you next question
listening to you I become even more
pessimistic than I was when I walked in
the door and that's that's life and I
guess my reaction was that and I haven't
read your book so I don't know if this
accurate is that what you've described
is faced with with what at least I
consider a real crisis you have two
schools of people who are far less
interested in figuring out how to solve
that crisis than and how to win over
their opponents on the issue of what
society they would like rather than
solving the crisis and it it does seem
to me that each of these different
schools the way of describe it has flaws
and has virtues and has imperfections
and neither as a sure thing and yet the
whole way the discussion has been
crafted is as pick aside and figure out
which side you're on and figure out
which side you think has the better
argument
when neither of them are slam dunks and
neither of them are short of winning and
both of them have complementary flaws
that that would lead that the other one
would have advantages too in different
circumstances and it does seem to me
that as an outsider both are necessary
and both some combination are necessary
and it sounds like from your description
that that's not the way anybody's
thinking about it or the way I'm I'm
guessing the way your book is thinking
about it from the way your this
discussion is gone which makes me very
fatalistic well thank you thank you
thank you I mean I guess just to respond
there's nothing that there's no law of
nature that says you can't have both but
you know you'll see when people advocate
nuclear power
you know they typically immediately go
on to trashing solar energy and the
renewables crowd immediately goes on to
trash a nuclear now be a clear example
or the same thing with GMOs and organics
and so there there are these fights and
they've gone on for a long time and even
though researchers like the person who
talked just before you say that these
are not necessary and I'm talking about
the you know the public here and the
they do seem to be in this real that the
real thing for discussion is to break
that down I've rather than to say pick
aside oh I don't think I said look I
just trying to say this is what's going
on we've got a lot of people lying or at
least a few people lined up but we're
running out of time so this is the last
question and B six things because we've
got a ok clear the space thanks very
much
I just wanted to ask you if whom you
would who would you consider to be the
most knowledgeable honest and open
intellectual heirs to dr. bola Borlaug
and to what mister vote as if to say as
was on the public sphere
you know his public advocate's or is he
nice fear you know a very influential
straight-up wizard is is Bill Gates you
know I mean and this whole school of
people that are like him and and equally
influential I would argue you know
straight up prophet where you could pick
people like Wendell Berry you could pick
people like Bill McKibben
you know there's quite a quite a few
people in in in in that in that realm
taking any kind of middle ground true Oh
who's forgetting the middle ground
that's a that's a really good there's a
Charles man yeah
[Applause]
well every month